françois durpaire historien et
spécialiste des états unis françois
durpaire bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors l'heure
est donc à la fois la première primaire
démocrate dans le petit état du new
hampshire dans le nord-est des
etats-unis est ce qu'on peut parler d'un
vote crucial pour les candidats ça c'est
un peu comme les commentateurs sportifs
il voudrait voir tous les matches comme
des matches très importants
je vais un peu décevoir c'est pas
forcément le vote crucial c'est pas
forcément le moment qui va faire tout
basculer je vous donne un exemple pour
étayer un peu ma mon argumentation
si joe biden père dans le new york times
on pourra pas dire que thomas hayden qui
était encore favori il y a quelques
jours sera définitivement éliminé
pourquoi parce que joe biden son test ce
sera la caroline du sud
s'il perd en 48 du sud alors là oui joe
biden sera totalement éliminés et et
quid par exemple de bloomberg bloomberg
lui va intervenir qu'au moment du super
tuesday le 3 mars donc vous voyez c'est
un vote important qui va peut-être un
peu clarifié les choses mais c'est pas
le vote décisif s'est invité on l'a vu
dans la campagne avec un meeting
justement dans le new hampshire
ils sont tous faibles at-il décocher les
hostilités sont donc bien lancée oui
c'est à dire qu'en fait la stratégie de
d'un train elle est très très clair il
va aller je vais utiliser une expression
un peu un petit peu populaire il va
suivre à la culotte les démocrates
si à qui vous savez qu'il ya une
primaire républicaine donc il va lui
faire sa primaire et vous avez vu de son
discours n'est pas un discours de
primaire ils sont intéressés et pas de
battre les autres républicains sait très
bien que c'est lui le candidat
républicain son intérêt c'est de montrer
aux électeurs que lui il est déjà dans
l'élection générale
il n'est pas dans l'élection primaire
eelv élections générales et au moment où
eux sont en train de se battre et bien
lui
il est en train de dire on va remporter
l'iowa on va remporter le new york times
et il est déjà dans sa campagne donc il
est en train de prendre un temps
d'avancé sur les démocrates et puis en
fait ce qu'ils disent sur les démocrates
les démocrates le disent eux-mêmes sur
eux mêmes vous entendez le débat
télévisé thunders trop à gauche c'est
pas de date krumm qui le dit ce sont les
autres démocrates by donne trop
establishment c'est pas by dane qui le
dis c'est pas ses patronnes qui le dit
ce sont les démocrates budget drop et
experts trop inexpérimenté ce sont les
démocrates qui le disent
etc etc alors dans le new hampshire est
ce que l'on peut s'attendre à un vote
similaire à celui de l'iowa la semaine
dernière à savoir un résultat très serré
pour entre petites boutiques the edge en
tête et bernie sanders tout juste
derrière ça change guère des sondeurs
arrive en tête dans les sondages dans
cette région oui alors bernie sanders
vous avez remarqué qu'il est en tête
dans le new hampshire et qu'il est
maintenant en tête dans le sondage
national il passe devant joe biden il
devient vraiment pour le moment en tout
cas le favori de cette campagne primaire
alors on peut penser que oui vous avez
raison ça sera peut-être un peu près le
même résultat que dans l'iowa pour
quelles raisons basse et la sociologie
du new hampshire
cet état dont on dit parfois qu'il est
le live free or die tijd le l'état dû
mourir vivre libre ou mourir c'est un
état qui très à gauche dans sa
circonscription nord un état ouvrier qui
pourrait donner savoir à saunders dans
le sud de l'état c'est en fait une
grande banlieue de boston et on peut
penser que la des zones périurbaines
pourrait voter pour beauty djedj donc on
pourrait effectivement avoir le bébé
vote alors à saunders un sud abouti jane
est un bel homme qui pourrait être
encore assez loin on pourrait encore
avoir c'est ces deux favoris
mais attention si demain on dit c'est
ses beauty djedj essais sanders qui
gagne on pourra pas dire comme il y a
quatre ans comme il ya huit ans voilà le
duel qui nous attend sa vie il ya
toujours un duel chez les démocrates
on a vu en 2008 obama versus clinton on
a vu en 2016
saunders versus clinton est bien là on
pourra pas dire demain ça sera aboutie
jays versus sanders parce que c'est
encore trop compliqué c'est encore trop
confus chez les démocrates
la vérité c'est que parmi les sept qui
était présent lors du débat de ce
week-end eh bien les 7 peuvent presque
encore se dire je vais gagner et cette
plus simple parce que bloomberg peut se
dire qu'il a aussi ses chances alors
vous parliez à l'instant de ce sondage
paru hier de l'université quinnipiac
pour la première fois vous lisiez bernie
sanders arrive devant joe biden est ce
que on peut parler d'un tournant
spectaculaire et si oui qu'est ce qu'il
révèle alors sanders il est très
clairement dans ce qu'on appelle aux
états unis le momentum
il est à pourrait d'ailleurs effectué la
passe de trois en emportant les trois
premiers états parce que vous savez qu
ensuite on va dans le nevada dans le
nevada les les syndicats sont très
importants et donc on a vraiment une
période très important pour % d'heures
alors évidemment ce qui est intéressant
c'est de voir comment le finalement il
se reproduit un peu dans le parti
démocrate ce qui s'est produit à quatre
ans au parti républicain
c'est avec les républicains qui se sont
dit mais qu'est ce qui est en train de
se passer
mas c'est donald trump qui semble avoir
les faveurs des électeurs républicains
et la l'establishment républicain il
n'était pas très content cette situation
là il y avait une guerre entre
l'establishment démocrate et sanders qui
a été déclarée la semaine dernière au
moment où tom perez le chef du parti
démocrate a demandé un recomptage dans
l'iowa sa sanders il n'a pas du tout
apprécié
d'ailleurs il avait déjà reproché un
petit peu la cacophonie
il l'avait attribuée à ceux qui ont
élaboré
vous savez la fameuse application de
comptage des amis d'hillary clinton
comme par hasard qui a eu cette un peu
théorie du complot qui est arrivé en
tout cas cette opposition très très
nette en train sanders qui n'a pas les
faveurs de l'establishment mais qui
pourrait très bien avoir les faveurs des
électeurs démocrates alors toujours
d'après ce fameux sondages derrière eux
l'ex-maire de new york vous en parliez
bloomberg et qui m'ont dit à la
troisième place avec une hausse
remarquable par rapport à janvier
comment est-ce qu'on peut expliquer
cette poussée on explique de deux
manières d'abord parce que c'est les
effets des premiers de ses proches de
ses premières campagnes de publicité il
a investi énormément et on va voir
notamment reçu dans le moment du super
tuesday les effets de l'argent qu'ils
dépensent dans la campagne mais c'est
aussi sa stratégie qui est payante
puisque finalement au départ on se dit
c'est pas très malin de par venir dans
l'iowa ne pas venir dans le nu en chat
parce qu'il faut respecter la démocratie
d'ailleurs donald trump et et année dans
l'iowa mais il aurait très bien pu
commencer au super tuesday et finalement
et l'a77 ce bazar il faut bien dire au
sein du parti démocrate sert les
intérêts de groupes berne qui finalement
arrive pour beaucoup d'électeurs comme
une sorte et biens de secours
et puis le deuxième atout de bloomberg
et bien c'est un peu la difficulté des
modérés et en particulier de baden
bloomberg il se situe au centre du parti
n'est pas à gauche et donc joe biden
apparaissant comme laissant la place de
se modérer il ya derrière d'outils jet
mais comment va-t-il se comporter dans
les états du sud et notamment avec les
minorités il ya également clos bouchard
mais vous voyez entre joe biden beauty
jet clos bouchard aucun de ces trois
modérés ne parvient vraiment à
très sa capacité à l'emporter et donc
dans ce contexte là blueberry là il
arrive comme un candidat on dit aux
états unis et victimes veulent un
candidat en mesure de battre donald
trump parce que c'est la grande question
en fait que se posent tous et démocrates
se pose même pas la question de savoir
quel sera le meilleur président ou quel
est celui qu'on aime le plus
il se pose la question de quel est parmi
tous ceux là celui qui peut battre 2-1
train pour l'instant il faut bien dire
qu'ils sont un peu pessimiste et ils se
disent on a pas forcément de grandes
chances pas ça donne un tram mais
attention une semaine en politique c'est
long on n'est pas encore au 3 devant
pourtant effectivement un toujours selon
l'université quinnipiac dans un éventuel
duel face à donald trump tous les
principaux candidats arriverait
vainqueur alors quelle valeur à cette
projection à plus de six mois du scrutin
vous savez sur les mêmes projections qui
effectivement je vous rappelle que il ya
quatre ans dans les oppositions un peu
nationale comme ça sans prendre en
compte le chemin qui nous mène à
l'élection et à part avec pas mais en
prenant en compte uniquement le sondage
national
ils arrêtent les tod l'emporter face à
donald trump pendant toute la campagne
aucun moment où donald grade n'était
apparu devant hillary clinton
et pourtant vous savez que à la maison
blanche n'est pas hillary clinton
c'est bien donald trump donc c'est son
âge il faut les prendre avec beaucoup de
pincettes
il faut plutôt examiner le chemin qui va
conduire à l'éviction c'est à dire les
scores que pourrait faire d'un train
dans le whisky dans l'ohio en
pennsylvanie en floride
c'est un état fédéral il faut vraiment
prendre en compte cette considération et
peut-être mettre de côté cette
opposition un peu factice de sondages
nationaux
je rappelle qu'aujourd'hui donald trump
est à 49 % de popularité il n'a jamais
lu plus de 50%
et il ajoute d'ailleurs jamais gagné
avec 50 % donc il lui suffit finalement
de trouver un chemin dans ces états pour
l'emporter
dans quelques mois son atout principal
étant évidemment la bonne santé
économique des etats-unis 63% des
américains sont satisfaits de l'économie
et puis va-t-il y avoir un effet
acquittement pour rappeler que bill
clinton avait 72 % de popularité
juste après son acquittement et bien
donald trump pourrait aussi bénéficier
de ce2 ce2 cet acquittement être être
renforcées dans les sondages d'opinion
merci beaucoup françois durpaire pour
travailler je rappelle que vous êtes
historien et spécialiste des états unis